il était où en fait vous avez une petite
garçonnière qui était dans un hôtel dans
Paris et vous vous m'appeliez et
il a le ménage à faire non il était 15h
et tu dis j'ai loué cette cette chambre
à l'année et ça sera à 15h et personne
ne le sera jamais et je te fais
confiance et si tu me fais confiance
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
avec vous vous étiez vous oui oui
vous avez sonné vous étiez tout nu et je
vous explique j'ai ouvert la porte et
vous m'avez fait kikou
j'ai pas compris vous étiez à poil avec
ce kikou là le kikou ça m'a réveillé et
ça m'a fait
non mais ça saisi
un kikou ça saisit le kit
de tous les kiki
j'attends les rêves des autres
à la fin on va d'abord faire Gilles
Verdez moi plusieurs fois mais c'est des
rêves en fait c'est c'est si je puis
dire pire parce que c'est pas des rêves
c'est des pensées nocturnes
c'est conscient voilà conscient et
volontaire tu as envie qu'il te
déglingue
ou l'inverse ou l'inverse
non il me plaît le petit blond là c'est
vrai
vous je sais pas lui c'est vous moi
j'avoue tout respect bien sûr mais si je
pouvais si je devais j'aimerais beaucoup
faire l'amour avec Delphine c'est pas
possible toi avec Genton vous Jean-Marie
et Daniel
Daniel c'est un peu avec tout le monde
Daniel c'est une journée portes ouvertes
c'est la
[Rires]
porte de marque
[Applaudissements]
sur la gueule
toi
j'ai rêvé hier soir pas plus tard que
cette nuit qu'on était déjà le 8 mars le
match était fini on faisait les tirs au
but
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ne passe pas ce que je pense que le PSG
va gagner je vous embrasse mon
Christophe Galtier
pour la Coupe du Monde j'avais dit la
France gagnante ils sont passés à ça moi
je suis encore en train de faire de la
mimolette donc
c'est bon moi j'ai dit
non je suis monsieur remis avec ma meuf
depuis trois mois donc si je pouvais
passer mon tour ça m'arrangerait un tout
petit peu là c'est avec ça va ta meuf
elle est hyper sympa
nous embrouiller
que d'ici hein Clara elle est venue
souvent du coup ça me rappelait des
longs-métrages des choses
[Rires]
[Musique]
tranquille
c'est farade espagnole tu bouges pas une
oreille hein elle me dit tu es drôlement
beau c'est qui qui t'habille j'ai dit
c'est Cathy elle me dit c'est qui
celle-là
il y a rien à manger là-dessus c'est un
tout petit bout de ça mais tout vas-y
donne-moi sa photo ah ouais je suis
limite à les limites de venir pour lui
tendre le coup je t'ai prévenu Cathy
c'est vrai que ma bibi adore Cathy
dites pas que c'est trop petit
[Rires]
je sais pas ce qu'il y a une chose grand
comme Daniel
j'ai rien compris allez on passe à
autrement on va faire Guillaume d'abord
après tu veux moi j'ai fait un rêve très
bizarre avec Gilles et j'ai cherché
la signification sur Doctissimo j'ai pas
trouvé la mort quoi non en fait j'étais
sur ses genoux le chantait des comptines
et j'étais en couche il mettait du talc
sur les fesses
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je vous dirai bien que j'ai dormi avec
ma Dona mais elle était déjà prise avec
moi j'ai déjà rêvé plusieurs fois de
vous
par contre ce qui est con c'est que je
me souviens jamais de mes rêves
non je sais que je vous ai déjà vu dans
mes rêves à mon avis vous me demandez
une augmentation
dis-moi j'aimerais bien faire non mais
sans déconner derrière et vous moi j'ai
que des rêves sportifs de l'équipe alors
je le fais
parce que je joue mal c'est bon
la natation synchronisée
de faire des figures et tout moi je suis
nulle elle est plutôt bien meilleure que
moi et elle a plus de grâce que moi mais
on essaie et voilà et ça je fais souvent
des rêves comme ça avec Delphine et avec
Valou je fais du tir à l'arc
même dans la vie c'est vrai même dans
les rêves même dans les rêves que
Delphine je pense que Delphine
tu es nul mais c'est pas possible
au sommet
je pense que Delphine moi j'ai déjà fait
des rêves sur des surpris alors j'ai
déjà fait des rêves ou pas
bref prémonitoire
non pas du tout elle me rendait l'argent
tout simplement